so so now it looks like the bengals are
going to have a real chance to win the
afc north i mean they had chances to win
some of those games they dropped
back-to-back games at home but now they
figure out a way to go get a win the
ravens have a loss because they're
without lamar jackson so they take an l
the steelers come back and figure out a
way to get a win who do you think winds
up taking the north the bangles have
that three in one record in the division
which may wind up pushing them over the
top in this thing who would have thought
you know i look at the pittsburgh
steelers and you know mike thomas has
these guys fighting and cloning the
baltimore ravens we talked about it
they're very resilient team but at the
end of the day the most complete team is
the cincinnati bengals i believe they're
the most complete team there um joe
burrow and those weapons that he's got
those defense the young defenders flying
around it just seems like they have a
comfort level with one another and
they're starting to trust each other and
they're a very good team
it's going to wind up being a really
interesting
decision for for this entire browns
probably starting with stefanski even
above staffance and whether or not they
want to go all in on baker mayfield now
as the franchise quarterback rodney
because this year he's been hurt he's
battled through all kinds of injuries
this is one of the most pivotal games of
the season and he has to miss it because
of covet even as he's starting to get
healthy where would you even begin to
try to make the decision whether or not
baker mayfield is a franchise
quarterback and one that's worth paying
it may wind up being close to 30 some
million dollars per year
brother they had all these years to
figure it out you know he's like
you've got it right in front of you now
you have to decide and even if you don't
want to decide on a long-term contract
for this guy maybe what you can work out
is a fair one-year deal a really fair
one-year deal is that number 20 million
is it 25 million is it 22 million but
maybe a one-year deal maybe another
proven year so we can go out there you
know get some more weapons retool the
offense and see what you're really
working with what a healthy baker may
feel your thoughts
yeah
i i would do it i would do it i mean i
think people very quickly forget that
how bad cleveland was what was it 20
some quarterbacks that have gone through
there and and has he been playing like
baker mayfield you know he's been
playing like patrick mahomes this year
has been playing like one of the true
elites and of the young quarterbacks
that are in the league no he hasn't but
he's also been dealing with at least
three significant injuries i mean lower
body injuries that are affecting his
mobility affecting the bootlegs
everything that stevansky wants to do
with that offense but what's been
impressive to me is that he continues to
play right like baker wants to be in the
game he wants to be with his teammates
he's tough and and i've been around the
afc north for a long time ben
roethlisberger has been that guy for
pittsburgh that is battling through
things but he's always playing and
always giving you a chance to win given
what that defense is given that you have
jarvis landry leading that offense and
he seems to have a great relationship
with baker mayfield there's no way i'm
breaking this thing up and risking going
all the way back down the road of oh and
16 and losing season after losing season
i'm keeping stability and i'm keeping
baker mayfield and hoping he gets
healthy for next year
and maybe what you can do is maybe you
approach baker mayfield and say look
baker we want you here long term but we
can't pay you upper to 34 35 million
dollars a year if you want to take a
team friendly deal maybe we guarantee
you a little bit more but annually we're
not going to pay you maybe we pay you 25
million a year as opposed to 30 million
a year he's making money off the field
and plus that gives them leverage where
they can go out and they can go sign
some better players they can go out and
pursue more free agents and sign some of
their own upcoming free agents
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports